how many decisions have been made about
you today or this week or this year by
artificial intelligence
I will day I for a living so full
disclosure and kind of a negative and
because of kind of a nerd
wherever some new news story comes out
about artificial intelligence stealing
all our jobs or robots getting
citizenship of an actual country I'm the
person my friends and followers message
freaking out about the future we see
this everywhere this media panic that
our robot overlords are taking over we
could blame Hollywood for that but in
reality that's not the problem we should
be focusing on there is a more pressing
danger a bigger risk with AI that we
need to fix first so we're back to this
question how many decisions have been
made about you today by AI and how many
of these were based on your gender your
race or your background algorithms are
being used all the time to make
decisions about who we are and what we
want some of the women in this room will
know what I'm talking about if you've
been made to sit through those pregnancy
test adverts on YouTube like a thousand
times or you've scrolled past adverts of
fertility clinics on your Facebook feet
or in my case Indian marriage bureaus
but AI isn't just being used to make
decisions about what products we want to
buy or which show we want to binge watch
next I wonder how you'd feel about
someone who taught things like this a
black or latino person is less likely
than a white person to pay off their
loan on time
a person called John makes a better
programmer that a person called Mary a
black man is more likely to be a repeat
offender than a white man you're
probably thinking wow that sounds like a
pretty sexist racist person right these
are some real decisions that AI has made
very recently based on the biases it has
learned from us from the humans AI is
being used to help decide whether or not
you get that job interview how much you
pay for your car insurance how good your
credit score is and even what rating you
get in your annual performance review
but these decisions are all being
filtered through its assumptions about
our identity our race our gender or age
how is that happening now imagine an AI
is helping a hiring manager finds the
next tech leader in the company so far
the manager has been hiring mostly men
so the AI learns men are more likely to
be programmers than women and it's very
shortly from there too
men make better programmers and women we
have reinforced our own bias into the AI
and now it's screening out female
candidates hang on if a human hiring
manager did that we'd be outraged we
wouldn't allow it this kind of gender
discrimination is not okay and yet
somehow AI has become above the law
because a machine made the decision
that's not it
we are also reinforcing our bias in how
we interact with AI how often do you use
a voice assistants like Siri Alexa or
even Cortana they all have two things in
common one they can never get my name
right and second they are all female
they are designed to be an obedient
servants turning your lights on and off
ordering your shopping
you get Mele eyes too but they tend to
be more high-powered like IBM Watson
making business decisions Salesforce
Einsteinian
or Ross the robot lawyer support robots
even they suffer from sexism in the
workplace think about how these two
things combined and affect a kids
growing up in today's world around the
eye so they're doing some research for a
school project and they google images of
CEO the algorithm shows some results of
mostly men and now they Google personal
assistant as you can guess it shows them
mostly females and then they want to put
on some music and maybe order some food
and now they're barking orders at a
female voice of beating obedient female
voice assistant some of our brightest
minds are creating this technology today
technology that could they could have
created in any way they wanted and yet
they've chosen to create it in the style
of 1950s Mad Men secretary yeh but ok
don't worry this is not gonna end with
me telling you that we're all heading
toward sexist racist machines running
the world the good news about AI is that
it is entirely within our control we get
to teach the right values the right a
text to AI so there are three things we
can do one we can be aware of our own
biases and the bias in machines around
us too we can make sure there are
diverse teams building this technology
and three we have to give it diverse
experiences to learn from I can talk
about the first two from personal
experience when you work in technology
and you don't look like a Mark
Zuckerberg or Elon Musk your life is a
little bit difficult your ability gets
questioned here's just one example like
most developers
I often join online tech forums and
share my knowledge to help others and
I've found when I log on as myself with
my own
photo my own name I tend to get
questions or comments like this what
makes you think you're qualified to talk
about AI what makes you think you know
about machine learning so as you do I
made a new profile and this time instead
of my own picture I chose a cat with a
jetpack on it and I chose a name that
did not reveal my gender you can
probably guess where this is going right
said this time I didn't get any of those
patronizing comments about my ability
and I was able to actually get some work
done and it sucks guys I've been
building robots since I was fifteen I
have a few degrees in computer science
and yet I had to hide my gender in order
for my work to be taken seriously so
what's going on here our men just better
at technology than women another study
found that when women coders on one
platform hid their gender like myself
their code was accepted 4% more than men
so this is not about the talent this is
about an elitism in AI that says a
programmer needs to look like a certain
person what we really need to do to make
AI better is bring people from all kinds
of backgrounds we need people who can
write and tell stories to help us create
personalities of AI we need people who
can solve problems we need people who
face different challenges and we need
people who can tell us what are the real
issues that need fixing and help us find
ways that technology can actually fix it
because when people from diverse
backgrounds come together when we build
things in the right way the
possibilities are limitless
and that's what I want to end by talking
to you about less racist robots less
machines that are gonna take our jobs
and more about what technology can
actually achieve so yes some of the
energy in the world of AI
world of technology is going to be about
what ads you see on your stream but a
lot of it is going towards making the
world so much better think about a
pregnant woman in the Democratic
Republic of Congo who has to walk 17
hours to her nearest rural prenatal
clinic to get a check-up what if she
could get diagnosis on her phone instead
or think about what AI could do for this
one in three women in South Africa who
face domestic violence if it wasn't safe
to talk out loud they could get an AI
service to raise alarm get financial and
legal advice these are all real examples
of projects that people including myself
are working on right now using AI so I'm
sure in the next couple of days there
will be yet another news story about the
existential risk robots taking over and
coming for your jobs and when something
like that happens I know I'll get the
same messages worrying about the future
but I feel incredibly positive about
this technology this is our chance to
remake the world into a much more equal
place but to do that we need to build it
the right way from the get-go we need
people of different genders races
sexualities and backgrounds we need
women to be the makers and not just the
machines who do the makers bidding we
need to think very carefully what we
teach machines what data we give them so
they don't just repeat our own past
mistakes so I hope I leave you thinking
about two things first I hope you leave
thinking about bias today and that the
next time you scroll past an advert that
assumes you are interested in fraternity
clinics or online betting websites that
you think and remember that the same
technology is assuming that a black man
reoffend or that a woman is more likely
to be a personal assistance than a CEO
and the help that reminds you that we
need to do something about it and second
I hope you think about the fact that you
don't need to look a certain way or have
a certain background in engineering or
technology to create AI which is going
to be a phenomenal force for our future
you don't need to look like a Mark
Zuckerberg you can look like me and it
is up to all of us in this room to
convince the governments and the
corporations to build AI technology for
everyone including the edge cases and
for us all to get education about this
phenomenal technology in the future
because if we do that then we've only
just scratched the surface of what we
can achieve with AI thank you
[Applause]